je dirais que c'est la population qui a
gagné ces élections ce n'est pas un mois
annie commis en tant que personne
physique mais vraiment c'est une
victoire pour la population ici la
victoire de la population une ode à
l'épopée la première des priorités est
pas loin de faire un audit de faire un
état des lieux de la situation de la
collectivité pouvoir qu'est ce qu'il en
est de point de vue financier d'un point
de vue
ressources à la fois humaines
économiques etc et dans un deuxième
temps il ya un dossier qui est un groupe
c'est le dossier concernant les
négociations avec les agents municipaux
donc il faudra en fait le nez à terme ce
dossier et car je reste persuadé qu'une
municipalité c'est à la fois son conseil
municipal et ses agents municipaux qui
sont au service de la population qui est
l axe fort de notre programme doit vous
fait la différence selon vous alors l'ex
fort de notre programme c'est que
justement on a présenté un programme
avec des projets concrets et réalistes à
la population est d'ailleurs ce sont des
projets qui émanent d'ailleurs de la
population parce que nous avons vraiment
fait ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des
actions participatives l'a vraiment mis
en place une démarche participative
la population a été sollicité à maintes
reprises pour pouvoir justement élaborer
ce programme
[Musique]